Gary did not want to become a football player, no interest in the game at all. He was a timid kid, the kind of kid who in baseball would close his eyes when he was up at bat, he was so scared of getting hit by the ball. But when you're in high school, your personality is still up for grabs. And at Gary's high school, there was not one person, but two people with a very different vision of who he was. They were assistant high school football coaches and very noticeable, big personalities. And they were twins.
加里并不想成为一名橄榄球运动员，他对这项运动毫无兴趣。他是个胆小的孩子，打棒球时轮到他上场，他怕被球击中，总是会闭上眼睛。但在高中时期，人的性格还没有定型。在加里的高中，有两个和他想法截然不同的人。他们是高中的橄榄球助理教练，性格鲜明且非常引人注目。而且他们还是双胞胎。
And I didn't really know their name. I'd seen them around. They were super handsome and in great shape. I mean, they were ripped. And they would wear Gold's Gym tank tops and Jams, these shorts, these Hawaiian shorts. They would wear those. And they had really long hair. And they were very charming, charismatic, funny. And they were known as the Jetsyns, which was this self-proclaimed nickname, I think.
我其实并不知道他们的名字。我常常见到他们。他们长得超级帅，身材也很棒。我是说，他们肌肉线条非常清晰。他们常穿黄金健身房的工字背心和Jams短裤，就是那种夏威夷风格的短裤。他们就那样穿。他们的头发很长。他们非常迷人、有魅力、风趣。他们自称为“Jetsyns”，我觉得这是他们自己起的绰号。
Wait, they called themselves the Jetsyns?
等等，他们管自己叫Jetsyns？
Yeah.
是的。
They referred to themselves--
他们自称是——
Yeah, because the Jetsyns was people from the future. And they felt that they were like that. They were definitely the first people I ever noticed who referred to themselves in that-- is it the third person?
是的，因为“Jetsyns”是来自未来的人。他们觉得自己就是那样的人。他们绝对是我见过第一批以这种方式自称的人——这是第三人称，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
So the Jetsyns are coming to get you. The Jetsyns will see you. The Jetsyns--
所以“Jetsyns要来找你了”，“Jetsyns会看到你”，“Jetsyns……”
That's what they would say?
他们真的这么说吗？
Sometimes they would say, Johnny Jetsyn will be with you today. Joe Jetsyn will be with you tomorrow.
有时他们会说：“强尼·Jetsyn今天会陪你，乔·Jetsyn明天会陪你。”
They're like magical figures.
他们就像那种神奇的人物。
Yeah, they really were. [LAUGHING]
没错，他们确实是。（笑声）
And these magical figures, these assistant football coaches, they gave Gary his own nickname in the fall of junior year. It was not a glittery name like the Jetsyns, kind of the opposite, actually. Waste, they called him.
这些神奇的人物，这些橄榄球助理教练，在高三那年的秋天给了加里一个属于他自己的绰号。那不像“Jetsyns”那样闪亮，事实上恰恰相反。他们管他叫“废物”（Waste）。
As in waste of talent, to goad me into playing football.
意思是“人才浪费”，好激我上场打橄榄球。
They told him that football would get him a college scholarship. It'll get him girls. They said the newspaper would write about him. They wanted him on the team so badly because Gary was a giant compared to most of the kids playing football back then.
他们告诉他，打橄榄球能让他拿到大学奖学金，还能吸引女生。他们说报纸会报道他。他们非常想让他加入球队，因为在当时，加里对比大多数踢球的孩子简直是个巨人。
This was in Peabody, Massachusetts, a Boston suburb near Salem in the late '80s. Most high school players back then were 5' 9", 5' 10". Gary was 6' 6", 200 pounds. And he was athletic, played basketball on his high school team. Those coaches scolded him for his complete lack of aggression and for crying.
那是80年代末，马萨诸塞州皮博迪市，塞勒姆附近的一个波士顿郊区。当时大多数高中球员只有5英尺9英寸或5英尺10英寸高。加里身高6英尺6英寸，体重200磅。而且他很有运动天赋，是校篮球队的成员。那些教练责骂他完全缺乏侵略性，还因为他爱哭而训斥他。
What he really loved doing was art projects, going to the arts and crafts store, reading. He kept an enormous stuffed animal collection in his room, even in high school. He was also pretty depressed at the time. Gary is a comedian today, Gary Gulman. And on stage, when he tries to describe what he was like as a kid--
他真正喜欢做的是艺术项目、逛工艺品店、读书。即使到了高中，他的房间里还收藏着大量的毛绒玩具。当时他也相当抑郁。加里现在是一名喜剧演员，加里·古尔曼（Gary Gulman）。在舞台上，当他试图描述小时候的自己时——
I talk about being Charlie Brown. I say picture my childhood-- Charlie Brown if Snoopy had died. That was my--
我说我就是查理·布朗。我说想象一下我的童年——如果史努比死掉之后的查理·布朗。那就是我的——
[LAUGHING]
（笑声）
That was my childhood. I felt so sorry for him.
那就是我的童年。我为他感到难过。
Because Charlie Brown, the whole point of his character is that he's sad and lonely.
因为查理·布朗这个角色的核心点就是他又悲伤又孤独。
Yeah.
是的。
But even that wasn't lonely enough. You have to kill off his dog?
但连那样还不够孤独，你还得把他那条狗写死？
Yes. Yes.
是的，是的。
So when the Jetsyns started telling him that they were going to make him into a star, he laughed it off. He liked the attention from the Jetsyns, sure, but he did not consider this seriously at all. Football seemed brutal-- just nonstop, violent, physical contact.
所以当Jetsyns开始告诉他要把他培养成明星时，他只是付之一笑。当然，他喜欢Jetsyns对他的关注，但他根本没把这当回事。橄榄球看起来很野蛮，就是无休止的、暴力的肢体接触。
He did not think he could cut it. Guys he knew who played football, they were so tough. Gary, on the other hand, he got picked on. He got bullied. He was bullied out of Little League. So football? No way.
他觉得自己做不来。他认识的那些踢球的家伙，他们都很强硬。反观加里，他总是被欺负，被霸凌。他就是在小联盟时被霸凌出局的。所以打橄榄球？绝不可能。
And then his junior year ended. And just a couple of days into summer break-- it was June, 6:30 in the morning-- he got a phone call, woke him up. It's the twins.
然后高三结束了。暑假开始才几天——六月，早上6点30分——他接到一个电话，把他吵醒了。是那对双胞胎。
They said, Gulman, this is the Jetsyns. Meet us at the Universe Gym at 7:30. We are going to train the Gulman this summer, and get the Gulman a scholarship, and make the Gulman into a star. By the end of the summer, you will be 245 pounds and ripped like Arnold.
他们说：“古尔曼，我是Jetsyns。7点半在Universe健身房见。这个夏天我们要训练古尔曼，帮古尔曼争取奖学金，把古尔曼变成明星。夏天结束时，你会有245磅重，练得像阿诺德一样强壮。”
It was so weird and bold. And on the spur of the moment, he figures, what the hell? And he has this thought that you have sometimes as a kid. He thinks, these adults say I can do this. Maybe they're right.
这太奇怪、太大胆了。那一瞬间，他想，管他呢？他有了小孩子有时会有的那种想法。他心想，这些大人说我能行。也许他们是对的。
They were so convincing. They were so convincing.
他们太有说服力了。他们真的太有说服力了。
And then there was a part of you that thought, like, yes, magical men.
而且你内心深处也有部分心想，没错，神奇的人们。
[LAUGHING] It was intoxicating.
（笑声）这让人陶醉。
It was?
是吗？
Because they were so cool. And my entire life, my family was more of a don't get your hopes up type of attitude or philosophy, if things don't always work out the way you want them to. And so it was a very negative house. And I remember asking them. I said, you guys really think I'm going to play on this high school football team? I don't have that much experience. And they're answering-- should I swear?
因为他们太酷了。我这一生，我的家庭大多是一种“别抱太大希望”的态度或哲学，如果事情不总是按你想要的那样发展的话。所以那是一个非常消极的家庭。我记得我问过他们。我说，你们真的认为我能进校橄榄球队吗？我没什么经验。他们回答我——我可以骂人吗？
Say what really happened.
说出当时发生了什么。
Every single time I would ask them any kind of question, they'd say, fuck, yeah. And not everybody was using that expression back then. That was the first instance of somebody saying that to me instead of "don't get your hopes up" and "we'll see." It was, fuck, yeah. And I was like, oh my gosh. These guys are so, so exciting. And they believe in me.
每次我问他们任何问题，他们都会说：“去他妈的，当然能。”那时并不是每个人都用这种表达。这是我第一次听到有人对我说这种话，而不是“别抱太大希望”或“走着瞧”。那是“去他妈的，当然能”。我当时心想，我的天哪。这些人太让人兴奋了。他们相信我。
So that summer, every morning he works out with the Jetsyns from 7:30 to 9:30. Then they take him to a diner, and they buy him a big breakfast with eggs and other proteins. At night, sometimes they'd teach him running routes. Remember, Gary had never played football. And it was just like the Jetsyns said.
所以那个夏天，他每天早上7点半到9点半都和Jetsyns一起锻炼。然后他们带他去小餐馆，给他买一顿丰盛的早餐，里面有鸡蛋和其他蛋白质。晚上，有时他们会教他跑位路线。记住，加里从来没打过橄榄球。一切就像Jetsyns说的那样。
It was incredible. It was like a Rocky montage. I was getting stronger and bigger. And they would say things. They had this thing, "The Gulman is getting huge. The Gulman is getting huge."
这太不可思议了。就像《洛奇》里的蒙太奇片段。我变得越来越强壮、越来越大块。他们会说些口号，“古尔曼越来越壮了，古尔曼越来越壮了。”
And so by the end of the summer, how did you look?
那么夏天结束时，你看起来怎么样？
I looked fantastic, man. I'd grown my hair long like them. And clothes started to look really cool on me as I was filling out.
我看起来棒极了，伙计。我也像他们一样留了长发。随着我身材变壮，衣服穿在我身上也开始显得很酷了。
And they were right. I weighed 240 pounds. I could bench press 225 pounds. I ran a 48.40, which was very impressive to everybody. Everything about me had changed physically. I had built this really great costume.
他们是对的。我体重达到了240磅。卧推能推225磅。40码冲刺跑了4.8秒，这让所有人都印象深刻。我的一切在身体上都改变了。我打造了这套非常棒的“戏服”。
Why do you say costume?
你为什么说“戏服”？
Because it covered up who I really was. I was still the same Gary who cried at movies.
因为它掩盖了我真实的样子。我依然是那个看电影会哭的加里。
So you have this man costume--
所以你有这套“男人戏服”——
Yeah.
是的。
--that you're wearing, which is your new body.
——你穿在身上，也就是你的新身体。
Yes. I feel terrific.
是的。我感觉好极了。
And as it came time to start practices, you would think that he would be psyched to use this new body that he had created for the purpose it had been made for. Like, OK, he's Captain America. It's World War II. Bring on the Nazis. But in fact, he was terrified of just getting hit, of the physical contact that's just built into football.
当练习开始时，你会觉得他应该会很兴奋去利用他为了那个目的而打造的新身体。就像，好吧，他是美国队长。现在是二战。让纳粹放马过来吧。但事实上，他害怕被撞，害怕橄榄球中固有的那种肢体接触。
And a week before practice, he talks to a friend. And he says to the friend he doesn't think he can do it. He doesn't think he can go through with it. Should he call the Jetsyns and tell them he's thought it over? It's not for him.
练习前一周，他和一个朋友交谈。他告诉朋友他不认为自己能行。他不觉得他能坚持下去。他该打给Jetsyns说他仔细考虑过了吗？这不适合他。
I'll never forget what he said. He said, Gary, they will kill you. They spent their entire summer training you and feeding you. You can't. You have to go through with this.
我永远不会忘记他说的话。他说：“加里，他们会杀了你的。他们花了整个夏天训练你、喂养你。你不能放弃。你必须坚持下去。”
So he did. He went through with it. But the problem was, as John Jetsyn put it, he was a daisy in a field of wheat, a lamb among conquerors. You can put a kid into a tough guy costume, but it doesn't always make him into a tough guy.
于是他做了。他坚持了下来。但问题在于，正如约翰·Jetsyn所说，他是一片麦田里的一朵雏菊，一群征服者中的一只羔羊。你可以给孩子穿上硬汉的服装，但这并不总能把他变成一个硬汉。
And of course, adults are always trying to convince kids and inspire kids about who they can be. That's what good parents do. That's what good teachers do.
当然，大人们总是试图说服孩子，激励孩子，让他们相信自己能成为什么样的人。那是好父母会做的事。那是好老师会做的事。
But some kids, like Gary, just have trouble going along with the plan. They want to please the adults. They want to do what they're asked. But all the while, they genuinely wonder, can they actually become the person the adults are telling them to become? Is that them? Is that who they should be?
但有些孩子，像加里，就是很难跟上计划。他们想取悦大人们。他们想做被要求做的事。但与此同时，他们真心怀疑，他们真的能成为大人们口中那种人吗？那是他们吗？那是他们应该成为的样子吗？
And it's totally confusing for them. The adults in their lives seem to know what they're talking about. They're adults, for God's sake. They're supposed to know better. But the kids end up wondering in a really primal way, who am I?
这让他们感到极其困惑。生活中大人们似乎很清楚自己在说什么。看在上帝的份上，他们是大人。他们应该更懂。但孩子们最终会在极其原始的层面疑惑：我是谁？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in two acts. In the second act, adults make it so a woman can't even decide what is true about some of the most basic facts about her own history. But we're going to start with this story, act one, Gary's story, which we're calling "Jersey? Sure."
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，节目是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为两幕。第二幕中，大人们使得一个女人甚至无法判断关于她自己历史中最基本的事实。但我们要从这个故事开始，第一幕，加里的故事，我们将其称为“泽西？当然。”（Jersey? Sure.）
Gary went to his first football practice, and it was just as bad as he'd imagined it would be. Guys rush at him and smash into him on every play. It's totally painful. He's completely miserable, bruised. He was in this one play.
加里参加了第一次橄榄球练习，情况正如他想象的那样糟糕。每次进攻都有人冲过来撞他。这非常痛苦。他极其痛苦，全身淤青。有一次练习中，他遭了殃。
This guy hit me helmet to helmet. And it was so loud, like a gunshot. And everybody noticed it. And they called it a biz. And the way it got its name was they said-- and the Jetsyns told me this-- they said the biz is the sound that it makes when you get hit in the head during a game, which is-- [MAKES BUZZING SOUND]
这家伙头对头撞我。那声音太响了，像枪声一样。每个人都注意到了。他们管这叫“嗡响”（biz）。名字的由来是——Jetsyns告诉我的——他们说“biz”就是你在比赛中头部被击中时发出的声音，也就是……（发出嗡嗡声）
And each week, the guy who had the best hit on somebody else would get this T-shirt called the biz of the week T-shirt. And now we know that these things, these bizzes, they were concussions. But at the time, in 1988, the concussion protocol was pretty much, you good? You good?
每周，那个对别人撞击最狠的家伙会得到一件名为“每周最佳冲击”的T恤。现在我们知道这些撞击会导致脑震荡。但在1988年，脑震荡的应急方案基本就是：“你还好吗？你还好吗？”
And that first time that I got bizzed, the Jetsyns were so proud of me. They high-fived me, and they patted my head. "The Gulman got bizzed, his first biz!" I was laughing along with them, but I was like, I hope that never happens again.
第一次我被撞出那种声响时，Jetsyns为我感到骄傲。他们和我击掌，拍了拍我的头。“古尔曼被撞出‘biz’了，他的第一次！”我也跟着他们笑，但我心里想，希望那永远别再发生了。
So every day, Gary would show up at practice and hated it until, finally, they started to play real games. And these are just preseason scrimmages, but they're against other high schools. There's a crowd in the stands. That changed everything from the very first time they put him in on offense.
所以每天加里出现在练习场都非常讨厌，直到最后，他们开始进行真正的比赛。那只是季前赛的训练赛，但对手是其他高中。看台上坐满了观众。从他们第一次让他上场进攻时，一切都改变了。
They set up a play for me. It's this pass where they just throw it over the middle. They throw it up high. And nobody can reach as high as I can jump.
他们为我布置了一个战术。那个传球就是从中间抛过去。他们抛得很高。而没人能跳到我跳得那么高。
I catch it. It takes a couple of guys to bring me down, just because I'm big and I want to run away from contact. There were fans. And they were cheering. I will say that was exhilarating.
我接到了。那需要几个人才能把我拉倒，因为我块头大，而且我想跑开避免接触。有粉丝在看台。他们在欢呼。我必须说那让人心潮澎湃。
Coaches try him out on defense. He barely knows what he's doing. And he sacks the other side's quarterback.
教练让他尝试防守。他根本不知道自己在干什么。结果他擒杀了对方的四分卫。
I had no technique.
我毫无技巧。
Yeah.
是啊。
But I was just so much bigger than this kid that he couldn't outrun me, because he wasn't as fast as me, and he wasn't as strong as me. So I was able to wrestle him to the ground. Anyhow, we go into the locker room. And the coach is berating the other players on the team for not being aggressive.
但我比那个孩子大得多，他跑不过我，因为他没我快，也没我壮。所以我能把他摔倒在地。无论如何，我们回到更衣室。教练正在责骂队里的其他球员不够积极。
And he says, the only person out there sticking anybody-- which I don't know if they still use that expression, but I like that expression-- sticking anybody is Gary Gulman, a kid who never played football until this summer. And I had goose bumps. And it was like a movie.
他说：“场上唯一一个敢‘钉人’的——我不知道他们现在还用不用这个词，但我喜欢这个词——唯一一个敢去跟人硬碰硬的就是加里·古尔曼，一个直到今年夏天才开始打橄榄球的孩子。”我起了鸡皮疙瘩。那就像电影情节一样。
So it's all happening, just like Jetsyns said.
所以一切都在发生，就像Jetsyns说的那样。
All happening, just like the Jetsyns had said. It was uncanny.
一切都在发生，正如Jetsyns所说。真是不可思议。
Opening game of the real season, the coaches start him. This newbie player, he sacks the opposing quarterback right away. And on offense--
正式赛季的第一场比赛，教练让他首发。这个菜鸟球员立刻擒杀了对方的四分卫。而在进攻端——
They threw me the ball three times. I caught every single one. I mean, that night I go to my first high school party. I'd never--
他们三次把球传给我。我全部接到了。我是说，那天晚上我去了我人生中第一个高中派对。我从来没——
Really?
真的吗？
--gone to a high school party. And it was such a letdown. Because you see--
——去过高中派对。那真是大失所望。因为你看——
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
--high school parties in movies. They're so exciting. And there's sex.
——电影里的高中派对。它们那么刺激。还有性。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I just sat on a couch because I didn't drink. And it was an incredible letdown. But I was invited--
我只是坐在沙发上，因为我不喝酒。那真是让人无比失望。但我被邀请了——
But you were in. You were in. That's what's important.
但你进去了。你身处其中了。那才是重要的。
Yeah.
是啊。
You were there.
你在那里。
At the party.
在派对上。
You were there at the bad party.
你在那个糟糕的派对现场。
Yeah.
是啊。
You made it.
你成功了。
And then Sunday night, the night before school, a local newspaper reporter called me and interviewed me about this game. He said that I was the talk of the town. And it talked about how everybody knew the ball was coming to me, and they couldn't stop me. And just like the Jetsyns had said, there were going to be newspaper articles. There was a newspaper article in the Salem Evening News the next day that called me Mr. Raw Potential.
然后星期天晚上，上学的前一天，当地报纸的记者打电话给我采访了那场比赛。他说我是全城的谈资。报道里提到每个人都知道球会传给我，但他们无法阻止我。就像Jetsyns所说，会有报纸文章。第二天《塞勒姆晚报》刊登了一篇报道，称我为“未加工的潜力先生”。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是啊。
And it did not last. The season opener, his first great game, was also his last great game.
但这并没有持续下去。赛季揭幕战，他第一场精彩的比赛，也成了他最后一场精彩的比赛。
I had one more decent game where I caught a pass, and I made a really, really good tackle. But the teams started to do this thing where they would send guys to block me and my legs. And they would send a couple of guys, and they would just roll into my legs. I think it's called a cut block, if I remember properly, but that was how they would sort of neutralize me.
我还有过一场不错的比赛，接到一个传球，完成了一次非常非常好的铲球。但球队开始采取这种策略，他们会派人阻挡我的双腿。他们会派几个人过来，直接滚向我的腿。如果我没记错的话，这叫切断阻挡，那就是他们阻碍我的方式。
And didn't the Jetsyns have some technique you could use to get around that?
Jetsyns没给你什么技巧来应对吗？
No. Either they didn't suggest one, or I wasn't able to employ it.
没有。要么是他们没提建议，要么是我无法应用。
Opposing quarterbacks learned to stay away from the side of the line that Gary was on. So he wasn't sacking anyone anymore. And after this one time when Gary fumbled the ball on a big play at the goal line, suddenly he says they stopped sending him out for passes. So no more heroic catches. He wasn't making big plays. He was not living up to all that bright potential.
对方四分卫学会了远离加里所在的那一侧。所以他不再能擒杀任何人了。在加里有一次在球门线附近的大好机会中掉球后，他发现他们突然不再给他传球了。所以再也没有英雄式的接球。他没有再完成精彩表现。他没能达到那所有的耀眼潜力。
And some dark part of his personality kicked in, like maybe he was a waste after all. The man costume had fooled them for a while, but he was still the same person he had always been. He started to dread practices and games.
他性格中某些黑暗的部分被激发出来，仿佛他终究是个废物。那套“男人戏服”骗了他们一段时间，但他依然是他一直以来的那个人。他开始恐惧练习和比赛。
I would throw up before every game. On the sideline I would throw up because I was overcome by nerves and anxiety. I started to feel really lousy about myself, and my grades suffered.
每场比赛前我都会呕吐。在边线上我会呕吐，因为我被神经紧张和焦虑淹没了。我开始对自己感觉非常糟糕，成绩也一落千丈。
And I just knew that I was starting to disappoint these guys. And they never said anything. To their credit, they never said, wow, we really had high hopes for you. It sounds crazy. I still have nightmares about it.
我知道我开始让这些人失望了。但他们什么也没说。值得称赞的是，他们从没说过：“哇，我们对你期望很高。”这听起来很疯狂。我至今仍会做关于它的噩梦。
His plan back then was make it through the season, one game a week. Never play again.
他当时的计划是撑过这个赛季，一周一场比赛。然后永远不再打球。
And in the middle of this, a college football coach came into our locker room and introduced himself to me at my locker. And that was sort of a, what the hell is going on here?
就在这期间，一位大学橄榄球教练走进更衣室，在储物柜旁向我做了自我介绍。那简直就像是，这到底是怎么回事？
Introduced himself to you?
他向你做了自我介绍？
Yeah.
是啊。
And said what?
他说了什么？
He said, you had a great game, which I hadn't. And I am an assistant at Dartmouth College. And we'd love for you to take a visit to Dartmouth.
他说，你打了一场伟大的比赛，而我其实并没有。他说，我是达特茅斯学院的助理教练。我们很希望你能去达特茅斯参观。
OK, here's the thing that Gary didn't know or understand at the time. As disheartened as he was, his coaches did not think he was having a bad season. Sure, they weren't sending him out for passes, but the main reason for that, John Jetsyn told me on the phone, wasn't the fumble that Gary had made-- like Gary obsessed over-- it was that the quarterback couldn't throw reliable passes. Their team wasn't that good that year.
好的，加里当时并不知道或不理解的是，尽管他很沮丧，但他的教练并不认为他表现得很糟糕。当然，他们没给他传球，但约翰·Jetsyn在电话里告诉我，主因并不是加里掉球——像加里担心的那样——而是四分卫没法传出可靠的球。他们队那年表现并不好。
And sure, yes, Gary didn't know how to stay on his feet when players threw themselves at his ankles, but John Jetsyn says he'd only been playing football a few months. Of course he hadn't mastered that. There wasn't time to teach him everything.
当然，是的，加里不知道在球员冲向他脚踝时该如何保持平衡，但约翰·Jetsyn说他才刚打几个月球。他当然还没掌握那些。根本没时间教他所有东西。
The Jetsyns still saw Gary as a diamond in the rough. Gary was doing everything they asked, ran his plays well. He was more reliable than most of the team. And so the coaches did what they did with any player with a ton of potential. They took video of Gary's best game, that great first game, made a bunch of copies, and sent it around to colleges.
Jetsyns依然把加里视为一块璞玉。加里做了他们要求的所有事，跑位也很好。他比队里大多数人都可靠。所以教练做了他们对待任何拥有巨大潜力的球员都会做的事。他们拍下了加里表现最好那场比赛的视频，复印了好多份，寄给了各个大学。
And after seeing that video, a parade of recruiters showed up at Gary's school. He'd get called out of class to meet them. He was approached by Harvard, Holy Cross, UMass, University of New Hampshire, University of Maine, and some top Division 1A schools, Syracuse and Boston College, his favorite, who'd recently won the Cotton Bowl.
在看了视频后，一队队招募人员出现在加里的学校。他会被叫出教室去见他们。哈佛、圣十字、马萨诸塞大学、新罕布什尔大学、缅因大学，以及一些顶尖的1A级别大学，雪城大学和波士顿学院——他最喜欢的，最近刚赢了棉花碗的球队——都来找他。
And also, there were players on the team who were All-Americans. I mean, this was a big time program that played a big time schedule against Penn State, and Notre Dame, and Ohio State, and USC. I mean, they were big time football. And they had Heisman Trophy winner Doug Flutie. He was the hero to everybody in my neighborhood.
而且，队里还有些全美最佳阵容球员。我是说，这是一个大牌项目，打的是大牌赛程，对阵宾州州立、圣母大学、俄亥俄州立和南加州大学。我是说，那是顶级橄榄球。他们还有海斯曼奖得主道格·弗卢蒂（Doug Flutie）。他是我邻居所有人的英雄。
And what do you remember of them recruiting you?
你还记得他们如何招募你吗？
I remember this man, who I had seen on TV because he had recruited Doug Flutie. And he was a New England celebrity. His name was Jack Bicknell. I'll never forget it because he had an office at Boston College, and it overlooked the stadium. And he had a Heisman Trophy.
我记得这个男人，我在电视上见过他，因为他招募了道格·弗卢蒂。他是一位新英格兰的名人。他的名字是杰克·比克内尔（Jack Bicknell）。我永远不会忘记，因为他在波士顿学院有间办公室，正对着体育场。他还有一座海斯曼奖杯。
And he said, son-- I always loved being called son, and I would just melt. It's like an arm around the shoulder. I don't know what it is about that word. He said, son, I'm going to go ahead and offer you, which meant a scholarship. I'm going to offer you.
他说：“孩子……”我一直很喜欢被叫孩子，我瞬间就融化了。就像是肩膀上搭了一只手。我不知道那个词有什么魔力。他说：“孩子，我打算给你提供奖学金。”这意味着一份奖学金。我要招你。
And he said something to the effect of, you're 17 years old-- or maybe I was 18. He said, you have an NFL body. And I remember thinking, wow, I've really fooled another one. And part of me was thinking, I was afraid this was going to happen because I'm going to have to take this scholarship. And I know I'm going to be in over my head. And then the other side of it was, this is so exciting, and somebody believes in me.
他还说了类似这样的话，你17岁——也许我当时18岁。他说，你拥有NFL级别的身体。我记得我心想，哇，我又骗倒一个了。我内心一部分在想，我害怕这会发生，因为我得接受这笔奖学金。我知道我将面临巨大的挑战。而另一部分在想，这太让人兴奋了，有人相信我。
And did part of you feel like, oh, my god, I'm going to be playing for this incredible coach? Whatever problems I had in high school, this guy is the guy. He's a genius. He's going to fix whatever problem I had. I'm going to be a star.
那有没有一部分你觉得自己，哦天哪，我将要为这位不可思议的教练效力？我在高中有什么问题都不重要了，这个家伙就是那个关键。他是天才。他会解决我所有的障碍。我会成为明星。
Yeah.
是啊。
So he takes the scholarship. He says he has no idea how he would have paid for college without a football scholarship. He works out all summer. And by the time he gets to training camp, he was bigger than ever, 260 pounds. His speed and strength, one of the best on the team. But it's clear right away.
所以他接受了奖学金。他说如果没有橄榄球奖学金，他根本不知道怎么负担大学费用。他整个夏天都在锻炼。等他到了训练营时，他比以往任何时候都更强壮，260磅。他的速度和力量是队里最好的之一。但很快就变得明朗起来。
I just felt so small. I mean, these guys really were supermen. Their aggressiveness, their strength-- it wasn't the same sport. And it was quite clear early on to the other players that I wasn't like them. I didn't talk like--
我感到如此渺小。我是说，这些人真的是超人。他们的侵略性，他们的力量——这根本不是同一个运动。而且很快其他球员就看出来我和他们不一样。我说话不像——
Oh, is that true?
哦，是真的吗？
Yeah. And I could be pushed around. And I could be bullied. There were guys who were going to go on to the NFL. There was one player who played for the Vikings.
是啊。我容易被推挤。我容易被霸凌。队里有些家伙后来进了NFL。其中一个球员后来效力于维京人队。
And I remember one time I was lollygagging on a play, and he hit me and bizzed me. And he said to me afterwards-- and his nickname on the team was The Maniac, which you really have to do something impressive to get a nickname like that amongst these lunatics. He said to me, he said, you can't just stand there like that. I could have killed you. In the nicest way possible he said that he had let up, even though he had hit me harder than I had ever been hit in my life.
我记得有一次我在比赛中磨磨蹭蹭，他撞了我，让我“嗡响”了。事后他对我说——他在队里的绰号叫“疯子”（The Maniac），你真的得做出点令人印象深刻的事才能在这群疯子中得到这样的绰号。他对我说，他说，你不能就这样站在那儿。我本可以杀了你。他以尽可能友好的方式告诉我，他已经手下留情了，尽管那一撞是他这辈子感受过最狠的撞击。
Gary went into a full-blown depressive crisis-- not eating when he should've been eating like a horse, sleeping all the time, crying.
加里进入了一场全面的抑郁危机——该像马一样吃东西时却吃不下，总是睡觉，哭泣。
The prevailing thing going on in my head is, I want to kill myself. I'm worthless. I'm useless. Everybody hates me.
我脑子里主要在想的就是：我想自杀。我是个废柴。我是个没用的人。每个人都讨厌我。
And did you have this feeling of, oh, I'm actually as strong as any of these guys? You're stronger than most of them. You're faster than most of them.
那你有没有这种感觉，噢，其实我和这些家伙一样强？你比大多数人都强。你比大多数人都快。
Yeah.
是啊。
Like, I should be as good. Did you have a feeling of, well, if I just psych myself up in the right way, I'm going to be able to do this?
就像，我也应该一样好。你有没有这种感觉，只要我调整好心理状态，我就能做到？
Well, I just knew-- I knew who I was. And the problem is, I know who I am, and I hate him. I hate him. He's so weak. And he disappoints. And he lets down. And I just wanted to go back to the room and sleep and cry. Yeah.
好吧，我只是知道——我知道我是谁。问题在于，我知道我是谁，而且我恨他。我恨他。他太软弱了。他让人失望。他总是掉链子。我只想回到房间睡觉和哭泣。是啊。
Did you have your stuffed animals with you?
你带着那些毛绒玩具吗？
No, but I had brought my blankie. I grew up with a blankie that was in my crib, and I could never sleep without it. But it was this thing that I was so ashamed of and never spoke about, really, to anybody because I thought that if anybody ever found that out, they would just be like, this guy's insane and also a woman.
没，但我带了我的“小毯子”（blankie）。我是抱着它长大的，它一直在我的婴儿床里，没它我睡不着觉。但我对它感到非常羞耻，真的从来没对任何人提起过，因为我觉得如果有人发现这一点，他们会说：“这家伙疯了，而且还像个女人。”
Did you have a roommate?
你有室友吗？
I had a roommate, yeah.
我有室友，是的。
That you had to hide the blankie from?
你必须躲着室友藏那条毯子？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
And you would call it the blankie, not the blanket?
你管它叫blankie（小毯子），而不是blanket（毯子）？
No, I always-- I mean, I referred to him-- I referred to him-- I called him blankie.
不，我一直——我是说，我称它为——我叫它blankie。
And whatever happened to it?
后来它怎么了？
Oh, I still have it. It's on my pillow right now in Harlem, yeah.
哦，我还在用它。它现在就放在哈莱姆区的枕头上。
Wait. Wait. Seriously?
等等，等等。认真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Wait. How old are you?
等等。你多大了？
I'm 48.
我48岁了。
Do you need it?
你需要它吗？
No, but I-- it-- [SIGHS] I love it. It's there with the pillow. I put it in my computer bag so I can carry it on planes when I travel.
不，但我……我爱它。（叹气）它就在枕头旁边。我把它放在电脑包里，这样旅行坐飞机时我能带着它。
And is it a comfort?
它是一种安慰吗？
Yeah. It's a comfort. It helps me sleep. I don't know how common it is. And the fact that you keep asking me questions about it makes me think it's really odd.
是的。这是一种慰藉。它能帮我入睡。我不知道这有多常见。你一直不停问我关于它的问题，让我觉得这真的很奇怪。
But you'll have like-- people who you're sleeping with will come over, and they'll sleep in your bed. And there will be the blankie?
但你总会有……和你睡觉的人会过来，他们会睡在你的床上。那里会有那条小毯子？
Yeah, my partner, Shaday-- she's a woman-- she's been aware of it since we've been dating. Yeah.
是的，我的伴侣Shaday——她是个女性——我们约会以来她就知道了。是的。
Not a problem?
不是什么大问题？
Not a problem, not until today.
不是问题，直到今天。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Sorry. I'm not trying to blankie shame you.
抱歉。我不是想让你为小毯子感到羞耻。
[LAUGHING]
（笑声）
I'm not.
并没有。
Anyway, back in college, first time Gary goes home for the weekend he stays in his room, cries, and sleeps, and won't talk to anybody. And his brother suggests he find a therapist. The football team actually has counseling services set up for anybody who needs it. And when he gets back to school, Gary meets with the therapist, who asked him a lot of questions.
总之，在大学里，加里第一次周末回家时待在房间里，哭泣、睡觉，不跟任何人说话。他哥哥建议他找个心理咨询师。橄榄球队其实有为需要的人准备的心理咨询服务。回到学校后，加里见了咨询师，那人问了他很多问题。
And he said-- point blank, he said, why don't you just quit the football team? And I-- like, that was ludicrous to me. And the way I would explain it now is, you have to understand my entire identity is wrapped up in this. And if I quit, I will be proving the voice in my head that keeps telling me I'm weak, and soft, and worthless right.
他直言不讳地问：“你为什么不直接退出橄榄球队呢？”对我来说，这听起来太荒唐了。我现在能解释的是，你得明白我所有的自我认同都与此相关。如果我退出了，我就证明了脑子里那个一直说我软弱、温和、没用的声音是对的。
So he made it through the season. The doctor prescribed him antidepressants, and the sadness and ruminations lifted. And in the spring, Gary's therapist asked, what are you going to do about football for next year? And Gary was like, I'll continue till I graduate.
所以他坚持完成了赛季。医生给他开了抗抑郁药，悲伤和反刍思维减轻了。春天时，加里的咨询师问：“明年你打算怎么处理橄榄球？”加里说：“我会继续直到毕业。”
And he said, listen, I never give advice. It's not my place to give advice, but I'm going to give you some advice. You need to quit the football team.
他说：“听着，我从不给建议。这不是我该做的事，但我打算给你一个建议。你需要退出橄榄球队。”
I said, if I quit the football team, I don't get to wear the uniform. I don't get to wear that jacket that gets me special treatment in the cafeteria and makes me interesting to the other students and the professors. I said, if I'm not a football player, then who am I?
我说：“如果我退出橄榄球队，我就没法穿那套队服了。我就没法穿那件让我能在食堂享受特殊待遇、让我能吸引其他学生和教授注意的夹克了。如果我不是橄榄球运动员，那我又是谁？”
And he said-- and I'll never forget it, the best answer-- he said, you'll be a man. But he didn't mean it, you'll be masculine, you'll be macho. He meant, you'll be an adult.
他说了句——我永远不会忘记这个最好的答案——他说：“你将成为一个男人。”但他指的不是 masculinity（男子气概），不是 macho（大男子主义）。他指的是，你将成为一个成年人。
Gary quit the team. He did keep the scholarship. The counselor went to bat for him and convinced the school to let him keep it for four years. And that same year, the year he quit football, Gary took the first real steps towards a different vision of who he'd be as an adult, a vision that was not handed to him by any of the grownups in his life, not his coaches, or his parents, or his teachers, but something he invented for himself. That's the year he started writing jokes.
加里退出了球队。他确实保留了奖学金。咨询师为他争取到了机会，说服学校让他保留了四年。同一年，也就是他退出橄榄球的那一年，加里迈出了通往成年人愿景的真正第一步，这个愿景不是生命中任何大人交给他的——不是他的教练，不是他的父母，也不是他的老师，而是他自己创造的东西。那一年他开始写笑话。
Do you know that I listen to your show, and I've heard people reveal things about themselves that I wouldn't reveal?
你知道我听你的节目，听到人们透露了一些我绝不会透露的事情吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
And I never thought that the blankie would be one of those things, that there could be somebody being like, huh, I'd never tell anybody about a blanket. I could care less that everybody knows now.
我从没想过那条小毯子会是其中之一，可能会有人觉得，“呵，我绝不会告诉任何人关于毯子的事。”但我现在一点也不在乎每个人都知道了。
So you feel no self-consciousness about it at all?
所以你对此完全没有自我意识了吗？
Not anymore. I did for 47 years though. I only mentioned it on stage this this year. People laughed, and it redeemed everything.
不再有了。不过我有过47年。我今年才在舞台上提到它。人们笑了，那一切都释怀了。
No, no, no. Now that you say that, I don't want to make you feel weird about it.
不，不，不。既然你这么说了，我不想让你觉得奇怪。
No, no. I think it's healthy. But you love Charlie Brown. Who was the wisest character on the Peanuts cartoons?
不，不。我认为这很健康。但你喜欢查理·布朗。谁是花生漫画中最聪明的角色？
Linus?
莱纳斯（Linus）？
Yeah. And he had a blankie.
是啊。他有一条小毯子。
He was five.
他才五岁。
[LAUGHING]
（笑声）
He wasn't five.
他才不五岁。
All right, he's eight, or whatever he's supposed to be.
好吧，他八岁，或者无论他应该是多少岁。
No, you're right. He was old enough to have--
不，你是对的。他年龄足够——
He's a child.
他是个孩子。
No, he is a child. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
不，他是个孩子。是啊，是啊，是啊。
Gary has an HBO special coming out later this year called, Gary Gulman: The Great Depresh. If you're curious about his work, you can find it at garygulman.com.
加里今年晚些时候会在HBO推出一期特别节目，叫《加里·古尔曼：伟大的压抑》（Gary Gulman: The Great Depresh）。如果你对他的作品感兴趣，可以在garygulman.com找到。
Coming up, a 17-year-old tries to understand a moment that shaped her whole life. Fortunately for her, there's video. Unfortunately for her, it's more complicated than that. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一名17岁的女孩试图理解一个改变她一生的时刻。对她来说幸运的是，有视频记录。不幸的是，事情比那复杂得多。稍后回来，芝加哥公共广播电台，《美国生活》继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Here's Looking at You, Kid," stories of adults telling kids what they should think of themselves and kids trying to make sense of what they're told.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《看着你，孩子》，讲述大人们告诉孩子们应该如何看待自己，而孩子们试图理解这些言论的故事。
We've arrived at act two of our program, act two, "Grownups Know Things." That act title was actually a line from Lord of the Flies. Piggy says it, that grownups have a cup of tea and talk things through. And then everything is all right. That's how grownups do it. It's hopeful, and of course, wrongheaded. So often things don't work out that well here in the adult world.
我们来到了节目的第二幕，《大人们知道事情》（Grownups Know Things）。那个幕名其实来自《蝇王》。小猪（Piggy）说的，大人们会喝杯茶，把事情谈清楚。然后一切就都好了。大人们就是这么做的。这很充满希望，当然，也是错误的。在成人世界里，事情往往不会进行得那么顺利。
But in the story, it's this moment where a bunch of the boys chime in with their desire that they could turn to adults. And in this next act, a girl turns to an adult with that same kind of hope that the adult will set things right. But over time, the adults that she turns to simply do not agree about some very fundamental things about her. Eleanor Gordon-Smith reported this story for a book she wrote.
但在故事里，这是一个男孩们渴望能向大人求助的瞬间。在接下来的这一幕中，一个女孩带着同样的希望向一个大人求助，希望能把事情搞清楚。但随着时间推移，她求助的大人们对她历史中一些非常基本的事实根本无法达成一致。埃莉诺·戈登-史密斯（Eleanor Gordon-Smith）为她写的一本书报道了这个故事。
I got interested in uncertainty years ago. There's a kind of uncertainty that we all live with where you don't know the answer, and it's not a big deal-- like what time the bus is coming, who left the front door open, where that pen went.
我几年前开始对不确定性产生兴趣。我们都生活在一种不确定性中，你不知道答案，但那没什么大不了——比如公交车什么时候到、谁没关前门、那支笔去哪儿了。
But I wanted to know about the opposite-- high stakes uncertainty where the facts aren't decisive, and it hurts to not know what to think, where there are big consequences, it affects your whole life. I wanted to know, is it possible to just sit in that kind of foundational doubt? Or do you just have to flip a coin and pick something, anything to believe?
但我想要了解的是相反的情况——高风险的不确定性，事实并不明确，而且不知道该想什么让人很痛苦，那里有巨大的后果，它影响你的一生。我想知道，在这种根本性的怀疑中是否可能仅仅坐着？还是说你必须掷硬币挑选某样东西，挑选任何东西去相信？
Which is how I got interested in Nicole Kleumper. She's 40 now, but this starts when she was 16. And she just couldn't catch a break. She was in foster care after her dad, who had sole custody of her for most of her life, had a stroke and died. She'd bounced around between friends' houses, but wound up in a group home.
这就是我如何对尼科尔·克伦珀（Nicole Kleumper）产生兴趣的原因。她现在40岁了，但这一切始于她16岁时。她当时命运多舛。她的父亲——她生命中大部分时间唯一的监护人——中风去世后，她进入了寄养系统。她辗转在朋友家，但最终落入了群体之家。
I just felt very adrift in the world and unanchored. Having lost my father, my best friend, I was so alone. And I just-- I was reaching out for something to feel connected to.
我感到在这个世界上非常漂泊，没有依靠。失去了我父亲，我最好的朋友，我太孤独了。我只是……我在寻找某种可以产生联系的东西。
She started really wanting to know about her mom. She lived nearby, just a couple hours drive, but they hadn't seen each other in more than 10 years. The custody court hadn't even allowed visits. And Nicole didn't know why. A quick warning-- what I'm about to go into mentions different kinds of abuse.
她开始非常渴望了解她的母亲。她住在附近，只需开车几个小时，但她们已经超过10年没见了。监护法院甚至不允许探视。尼科尔不知道为什么。一个简短的警告——接下来我提到的内容涉及不同种类的虐待。
Nicole had a foggy thought that her mom might have done something bad to her as a kid. She remembered saying something to someone when she was young about her mom burning her feet on a stove and remembered something about a sexual abuse allegation. But could that be right? Surely, she'd remember those things actually happening, but she didn't.
尼科尔有一个模糊的念头，她的母亲小时候可能对她做过坏事。她记得小时候对某人说起过她母亲在炉子上烫伤她脚的事，还记得关于性虐待指控的一些记忆。但这可能是真的吗？当然，她会记得那些事情实际发生的，但她不记得。
What if her dad had just made her say those things about her mom? It had been a really ugly custody battle. Each parent said all kinds of things about the other. What if her dad wanted custody so bad he invented all these awful stories?
如果她父亲只是让她编造那些关于母亲的事呢？那是一场非常丑陋的监护权之争。父母双方都在说对方的坏话。如果她父亲因为太想要监护权而编造了所有这些可怕的故事呢？
There was so much about her mom that Nicole didn't know, so she arranged to meet her mom in person. They did. They started seeing each other more regularly, but it always felt off. Once, she remembers sitting next to her mom at dinner and putting her head down on the table in front of her.
关于她母亲尼科尔有太多不知道的事情，所以她安排亲自见见她母亲。她们见面了。她们开始更频繁地见面，但总觉得哪里不对劲。有一次，她记得在晚餐时坐在母亲旁边，把头埋在前面的桌子上。
She rubbed my back, and it was very, very uncomfortable. And I had a pretty strong reaction to it.
她抚摸我的后背，那非常、非常不舒服。我对此反应很强烈。
Nicole says they didn't talk about any abuse. And then in the middle of that doubt, a piece of evidence seemed to fall from the sky, and with it, the promise of knowing what had happened in the custody dispute.
尼科尔说她们没有谈论任何虐待。然后在那种怀疑中，一件证据似乎从天而降，随之而来的是了解监护争议中发生了什么的承诺。
Dr. Dave Corwin phoned Nicole. He was the child psychiatrist in the custody battle that had split Nicole off from her mom. And he had videotapes of interviews he'd done with her when she was a very young girl.
戴夫·科温（Dave Corwin）医生给尼科尔打了电话。他正是当年监护权争夺战中，将尼科尔从她母亲身边分开的那位儿童精神科医生。他保存着尼科尔小时候接受采访的录像带。
It had been his job to investigate the abuse allegations. He'd had a question. He was speaking at a conference. Would it be OK if he showed those people the tapes?
调查虐待指控是他的工作。他有一个疑问。他正在一个会议上发言。如果他把那些录像带给人们看，可以吗？
Nicole remembered Corwin. She remembered that he'd been nice to her as a kid. She said, yeah, he could use them, but could she see those tapes too? He agreed and recorded their meeting.
尼科尔记得科温。她记得小时候他对她很好。她说，可以，他可以使用，但她也能看看那些录像带吗？他同意了，并记录了他们的会面。
I don't know the effect-- because it's never been done, to my knowledge-- this will have on you, OK?
我不知道结果会如何——因为据我所知还没人这么做过——这对你会有什么影响，好吧？
So I'm sitting across from Dr. Corwin, and there's a video camera. I'm getting ready to watch the tapes of myself at five years old. And he went through a very lengthy informed consent.
所以我坐在科温医生对面，前面有个摄像机。我准备好观看自己五岁时的录像带了。他进行了一个非常漫长的知情同意过程。
At this stage, you're 17 years old. What I'm doing is I'm doing this informed consent directly with you, saying here's the issues, as I understand them. And then it's up to you, OK?
在这个阶段，你17岁了。我正在直接和你进行知情同意，说明这里的问题，正如我所理解的那样。然后由你决定，好吧？
Finally, we got to the point where he was going to shut off the video camera so that I could watch my five-year-old self. And he asked me, what do you recall?
最终，我们到了他要关掉摄像机让我观看五岁自己的地步。他问我：“你记得什么？”
Why don't we start with, if you could just tell me what you can recall of that time.
我们从这里开始吧，如果你能告诉我就那个时期你记得什么。
I think I described one of the offices that he did one of the interviews in, in a striped sweatshirt that I was wearing at the time.
我想我描述了他进行采访的一间办公室，当时我穿着一件条纹运动衫。
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: I was wearing a sweatshirt that was striped this way, OK? I don't know why. When I think of these interviews, that's the first thing I think of.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我当时穿着一件这样条纹的运动衫，好的吗？我不知道为什么。当我想到这些采访时，这是我首先想到的事情。
17-year-old Nicole says she can't remember whether her mom really did hurt her.
17岁的尼科尔说她记不清她母亲是否真的伤害过她。
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: I told you, I guess, I told the court that my mom burned my feet on the stove. And I still don't remember if that's, in fact, how I was burned. Really, that's the most serious accusation against her that I remember. That's what I'm having a problem remembering.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我告诉过你，我想，我告诉法院我母亲在炉子上烫伤了我的脚。但我仍然不记得事实是否真的如此。真的，那是我记得的对她最严重的指控。那就是我记不清的事情。
I've come here trying not to determine already that she's done it or that she's guilty. And I've come here trying not to say, well, she's innocent. She didn't do anything. I refuse to believe she's done anything. I really want to know.
我来这里，试着不去预先判定她做过，或者她是有罪的。我来这里也试着不去说，好吧，她是无辜的。她什么也没做。我拒绝相信她做过任何事。我真的很想知道。
And then Corwin brings up the allegation of sex abuse.
然后科温提到了性虐待的指控。
David Corwin literally asks me, do you remember any allegations of sexual abuse?
戴夫·科温字面上问我：你记得任何关于性虐待的指控吗？
Concerns about possible sexual abuse?
关于可能发生的性虐待的担忧？
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: No.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：没有。
And my initial reaction is actually, no.
我最初的反应确实是“没有”。
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: I mean, I remember that was part of the accusation.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我是说，我记得那是指控的一部分。
And then he starts to speak, and I say, wait. Hold on a second.
然后他开始说话，我说：“等等。停一下。”
You don't remember any--
你不记得任何——
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: [INAUDIBLE] I do.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：（听不清）我记得。
17-year-old Nicole's whole demeanor changes at this moment. It's instant and kind of strange to watch. She becomes completely still, and she's staring into middle distance.
17岁的尼科尔此时的整个神态变了。那一刻是即时的，看起来有点奇怪。她变得完全静止，盯着虚无的中间距离。
What do you remember?
你记得什么？
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Oh, my gosh. That's really, really weird. I accused her of, when she was bathing me here, whatever, hurting me.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：哦，我的天。那真的、真的很奇怪。我指控她，当她在这里给我洗澡时，无论如何，她伤害了我。
And that's when I started to recount some details of a memory that came back to me.
就在那时，我开始讲述一段回到我脑海中的记忆细节。
As you're saying that to me, do you remember having said those things? Or you remember having experienced those things?
当你对我这么说时，你记得自己说过那些话吗？还是你记得经历过那些事？
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: I remember it happening, that she hurt me.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我记得那是真的，她伤害了我。
Hurt you, where, how?
在哪里，如何伤害你？
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: She hurt me.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：她伤害了我。
There's tissues right here, right over there.
纸巾就在这儿，在那边。
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: But see, I don't know if it was intentional hurt. She was bathing me. And I only remember one instance. And she hurt me. She put her fingers too far where she shouldn't have, and she hurt me. That's the first time I've remembered that since saying that when I was six years old, but I remember.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：但你看，我不知道那是否是故意的伤害。她在给我洗澡。我只记得那一次。她伤害了我。她把手指伸得太深，伸进了不该伸的地方，她伤害了我。这是我自六岁说出那话后第一次想起那件事，但我记得。
You remember being--
你记得被——
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Yeah, I remember it happening.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：是的，我记得那是真的。
OK.
好的。
It was like a movie set where the walls-- there's no roof, like I was sitting up on the walls looking down into a bathroom and my biological mother bathing younger me. And she touches me inappropriately. That's where the memory stops.
那就像电影片场，墙壁……没有屋顶，就像我坐在墙上往下看洗手间，我的生母在给小时候的我洗澡。她不恰当地触碰了我。记忆就停在那儿。
So it's like you're watching it from outside of yourself, from above?
所以就像你从自己之外，从上面看着它？
Yes. But I could feel the pain though. And I remember saying, it's like I took a snapshot of the pain.
是的。但我能感觉到那种痛。我记得当时说，就像我拍下了一张关于痛苦的快照。
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: A picture of the pain and what was inflicting the pain.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：一张痛苦的画面，以及是什么造成了那种痛苦。
It was my biological mother.
那是我的生母。
Even before she saw the tapes, Nicole at 17 felt she'd got the certainty she wanted. She remembered her mother actually hurting her. She watched the videos of herself as a small girl anyway. Corwin shut off the recorder while she did.
甚至在看录像带之前，17岁的尼科尔就觉得她得到了她想要的确定性。她记得她母亲真的伤害了她。无论如何，她还是观看了自己小时候的录像带。科温在观看时关掉了录音机。
And this remarkable thing happened. Nicole saw herself as a young girl, describing the very same abuse, almost verbatim.
发生了一件非凡的事。尼科尔看到了小时候的自己，几乎逐字逐句地描述了同样的虐待。
I've seen the videos. It's the '80s. A very small Nicole is in pigtails and white stockings. Corwin's in a big plaid shirt and shaggy hair. And he asks right away about Nicole's mom.
我看过那些录像。那是80年代。一个扎着小辫、穿着白袜的小尼科尔。科温穿着一件格子衫，留着蓬乱的头发。他立刻询问关于尼科尔母亲的事。
What's she like?
她是什么样的人？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Mean.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：坏人。
Why is she mean?
为什么她是坏人？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Hurts me.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：她伤害我。
How does she hurt you?
她是怎么伤害你的？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Like sticks her finger up my vagina, about up to there on my finger.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：就像把手指伸进我的阴道，差不多到手指那里。
When did she do that?
她什么时候这么做的？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: All the time when she gives me a bath.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：每次她给我洗澡的时候。
Uh-huh. What did you say to her when she did that to you?
嗯哼。她这么对你的时候你对她说了什么？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: I said, don't do that. I said, ouch.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我说，别这么做。我说，哎哟。
She says her mom burned her feet over a hot stove. Corwin tries to figure out if Nicole knows the difference between what's real and what's make believe. He asks her to separate things like President Reagan-- real, which she knows-- from things like Superman-- make believe, which she also knows. He gets her to swear on her oath as a Brownie that what she said about her mother is real. She does. She holds three little fingers up in the Brownie salute.
她说她母亲在热炉子上烫伤了她的脚。科温试图找出尼科尔是否知道现实和想象的区别。他让她分开那些事，比如里根总统——是真实的，她知道——还有像超人——是虚构的，她也知道。他让她作为布朗尼女童军（Brownie）宣誓，她对母亲所说的都是真的。她做到了。她举起三个手指，做布朗尼宣誓礼。
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: On my honor, I will try to serve God and my country.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我以名誉担保，我会努力为上帝和国家服务。
There are other concerning details about Nicole's mom. Once, she had dropped Nicole off to see Dr. Corwin for one of their recorded sessions. And Nicole, who'd seemed happy to be recorded and speak clearly into the microphone when her dad dropped her off, is suddenly concerned that the microphone would broadcast what she's saying into the waiting room where her mom sits.
还有其他关于尼科尔母亲的令人担忧的细节。有一次，她把尼科尔送到科温医生那里进行录音会谈之一。尼科尔在父亲送她去时看起来很高兴被录音并清晰地对着麦克风说话，突然担心麦克风会把她的话广播到母亲所在的候诊室里。
Corwin asks her about the abuse she described the week before. Did she remember talking about that? A little bit, Nicole says quietly.
科温问她关于前一周描述的虐待。她记得谈论过那个吗？尼科尔低声说，记得一点点。
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: I don't.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我不记得。
OK. Tell me the little bit that you remember.
好的。告诉我想起来的那一点点。
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Does that talk out to the waiting room?
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：那话会传到候诊室吗？
No, it doesn't. They can't hear us, OK? They can't hear us out there. And you're safe here, OK? And I'm not going to-- after we get done talking, I'm not going to tell them what you tell me, OK? It's just between you and I right now,
不，不会。他们听不到我们说话，好吧？他们听不到。你在这是安全的，好吧？我们谈完后，我也不会告诉他们你告诉我的事，好吧？这现在只是你和我之间的事。
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: (WHISPERS) OK.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：（低语）好的。
OK?
好吗？
OK, she whispers, before going on to talk about being burned and touched in the bath. In another interview, Nicole says her mother's told her to lie.
她低声说着，然后继续谈论被烫伤和在洗澡时被触摸的事。在另一次采访中，尼科尔说她母亲告诉她撒谎。
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: When's my dad going to be back?
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我爸爸什么时候回来？
Hm? I don't know. I don't know when he's going to come back.
嗯？我不知道。我不知道他什么时候回来。
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: He's in court.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：他在法院。
I guess. What's he in court about?
我想是吧。他在法院干什么？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: My mother.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：我母亲的事。
What about your mother? Do you know?
关于你母亲什么事？你知道吗？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: That she threatened me.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：她威胁我。
That she what?
她什么？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Threatened me.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：威胁我。
Threatened you? How's that?
威胁你？怎么威胁的？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Threatened me that if I didn't lie to the CPS, that she would do something bad to me.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：威胁我，如果我不对儿童保护服务（CPS）撒谎，她就会对我做坏事。
She's talking about CPS, Child Protective Services.
她说的是CPS，儿童保护服务。
If you didn't do what?
如果你不做什么？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: Lie to the CPS man.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：对CPS的人撒谎。
That she would do something bad?
说她会做坏事？
(SUBJECT) SIX-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: To me.
（受访者 六岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：对我。
Well, when did she say that?
嗯，她是什么时候这么说的？
So that's the video of six-year-old Nicole. Corwin then asks 17-year-old Nicole how she's feeling about what she just saw. She says there are some questions that might never be answered, but her biggest question about why she didn't grow up with her mom, that had an answer. She was sure her mom had abused her.
那就是六岁尼科尔的录像。科温随后问17岁的尼科尔看了刚才的视频感觉如何。她说有些问题可能永远没有答案，但关于为什么她没能和母亲一起长大的最大疑问，她得到了答案。她确信母亲虐待了她。
(SUBJECT) 17-YEAR-OLD NICOLE KLEUMPER: But I do have an explanation in my mind. And I can now realize it's not my fault. And I can put that chapter behind me, and I can go on. And yeah, I do think it's a very healthy thing to not run from something.
（受访者 17岁的尼科尔·克伦珀）：但我脑子里有了解释。我现在能意识到那不是我的错。我可以把那一章抛在脑后，我能继续前行。是的，我觉得不逃避某事确实是非常健康的事。
For Nicole, the tapes end her memory, proved what had happened to her as a kid. It was a relief. She'd been worried that she was going to learn that her dad really did coach her to lie about her mom. Now she could put that aside. She could remember him the way she always had, as her best friend and a good dad.
对尼科尔来说，录像带终结了她的记忆，证明了小时候发生了什么。那是一种解脱。她一直担心自己会得知父亲真的教唆她对母亲撒谎。现在她可以把那放在一边了。她可以像以前一样记得他，作为最好的朋友和一个好父亲。
But then Corwin published a case study about Nicole. He didn't use her name. He called her Jane Doe. But Corwin's case study became part of a huge dispute that was fracturing psychology in the '90s.
但科温发表了一个关于尼科尔的个案研究。他没用她的真名。他称她为“简·多伊”（Jane Doe）。但科温的个案研究成了90年代心理学界巨大争端的一部分。
It was called the memory wars. And the argument was about whether repressed memories, adults suddenly remembering trauma, were real. Some scientists believed repressed memories were possible, others said no way.
这被称为“记忆战争”。争论的主题是关于“压抑记忆”（repressed memories）——即成年人突然回忆起创伤——是否真实。一些科学家认为压抑记忆是可能的，另一些则说绝不可能。
Nicole's videotapes and Corwin's article were co-opted by the side that thought repressed memories were real. They thought Nicole's case proved it. Corwin hadn't seen this coming. I've spoken to him. He says he wasn't on either side.
尼科尔的录像带和科温的文章被认为压抑记忆真实存在的一方所利用。他们认为尼科尔的案例证明了这一点。科温没料到这一点。我和他谈过。他说他并不站在任何一方。
Dr. Elizabeth Loftus read Corwin's article with one eyebrow firmly raised. She was a psychology professor at the University of Washington and a big deal. It was her experiments that proved memories are malleable. And she was a star witness in high profile court cases where she argued that eyewitness recollections aren't reliable.
伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯（Elizabeth Loftus）教授读了科温的文章，挑起了一边的眉毛。她是华盛顿大学的心理学教授，大人物。是她的实验证明了记忆是可塑的。她是高调法庭案例中的明星证人，她在那里争辩说目击者的回忆是不可靠的。
So when the memory wars began, she knew which side she was on. She thought repressed memories were almost never real. She wrote a doorstop of a book called, The Myth of Repressed Memory. And when she read the Jane Doe case, she was alarmed.
所以当记忆战争开始时，她知道自己站在哪一边。她认为压抑记忆几乎从来不是真实的。她写了一本关于压抑记忆神话的书。当她读到简·多伊案例时，她感到震惊。
I knew that people were using this case as the new proof of repressed memory. It was being discussed academically. It was being introduced into court cases to prove that repressed memory is real and has been proven. It was being used against people whom I thought were innocent because they were on trial in their cases. And so we had to get to the bottom of it.
我知道人们在使用这个案例作为压抑记忆的新证明。它正在学术界被讨论。它正在被引入法庭案例来证明压抑记忆是真实的且已被证明。它被用来针对那些我认为是无辜的人，因为他们在自己的案件中接受审判。所以我们必须弄清楚真相。
Part of her suspicion was the message, and part was the messenger. She'd seen Corwin testify in court on another case. A patient accused their therapist of abuse, and she didn't find him persuasive there either.
她怀疑的一部分是文章信息，另一部分是信息发送者。她曾在另一个案子中看到科温在法庭作证。一名病人指控他们的治疗师虐待，她觉得他在那儿也不具说服力。
I already had a suspicion about Corwin and his judgment, I think, going into this situation because of the work I had seen him do on this other case and how he had pretty much helped to ruin the life of this poor female psychiatrist who was the accused person in this other case.
因为我在另一个案子中看到他做过的工作，以及他如何帮助毁了那个被指控为罪犯的可怜女性精神科医生的生活，我在面对这种情况时，就已经对科温和他的判断力产生了怀疑。
You're saying that the female psychiatrist was accused of abuse?
你是说女性精神科医生被指控虐待？
Yes, by, I think, a former patient.
是的，据我想，是一名以前的病人。
And Corwin was saying that that had happened?
而科温说那发生了？
In so many words, yes. He was an expert for the accuser.
用那么多话来说，是的。他是原告的专家。
Loftus decided to investigate the Jane Doe case. She wanted to know whether the abuse had really happened. But to do that, she needed to know the real name of that little girl. Rather than ask Corwin, which would be normal for a researcher looking into someone else's study, she decided to dig around on her own. Loftus knew where to start.
洛夫特斯决定调查简·多伊案例。她想知道虐待是否真的发生过。但为了做到这一点，她需要知道那个小女孩的真名。她没有询问科温（对于研究他人研究的人来说这很正常），而是决定自己挖掘。洛夫特斯知道从哪儿开始。
Clues in the tapes. At some point in the tape, he called her Nicole. And I just made a little mental note. Hm, her name is Nicole. He said something like, and when you were living in Fresno. And I thought, hm, it has something to do with Fresno, that kind of thing.
录像带里的线索。在录像带某处，他叫她尼科尔。我做了一个小的心理笔记。嗯，她的名字是尼科尔。他说了一些类似“当你住在弗雷斯诺（Fresno）时”的话。我想，嗯，这和弗雷斯诺有关，那种事。
She contacted a private investigator to run down some tips. She searched death records for Nicole's father. She found dozens of matches. And she started narrowing them down, closing in on the real Jane Doe.
她联系了一名私家侦探来搜寻线索。她搜索了尼科尔父亲的死亡记录。她找到了几十个匹配项。她开始缩小范围，接近真实的简·多伊。
Nicole, meanwhile, was thinking very little about her time as Jane Doe. She left foster care and was making her own life as an adult. She joined the Navy. She was learning to fly military helicopters.
与此同时，尼科尔很少想到她作为简·多伊的那段日子。她离开寄养系统，作为一个成年人创造了自己的生活。她加入了海军。她学习驾驶军事直升机。
And she decided to become a psychologist, she says, because she wanted to be like Corwin. She felt safe when she was talking to him as a kid, when she was being listened to. She wanted to make other people feel that way. She started acing her psychology classes at night while she trained as a pilot during the day. A couple of years into her military service, stationed in Hawaii, she got an odd phone call from a close family friend.
她说她决定成为一名心理学家，因为她想变得像科温一样。当她小时候与他交谈，当她被倾听时，她感到安全。她想让其他人也有那种感觉。她在白天进行飞行训练的同时，晚上开始攻读心理学课程并获得高分。在她服兵役几年后，驻扎在夏威夷时，她接到一个亲密家庭朋友打来的奇怪电话。
Said, hey, there's something going on. There's a private investigator looking for you.
他说：“嘿，出事了。有个私家侦探在找你。”
And what did you think?
当时你觉得怎么样？
Oh, my gosh. Why on earth? What on earth? What is happening now? And I knew within moments of hearing the words "private investigator" that this had something to do with Dave's journal article.
哦，我的天。为什么？为什么？发生了什么事？当听到“私家侦探”这几个字时，我瞬间就知道这和戴夫的期刊文章有关。
It was the only thing she'd ever been part of that might be interesting to an investigator. She called Corwin, who learned Loftus was behind it. Loftus interviewed Nicole's foster mom, former step-mom, family friends who knew her growing up. She'd even interviewed Nicole's biological mom and said she might have been wrongly accused. Nicole, hearing about Loftus, was like, absolutely not.
那是她经历过的唯一一件可能引起调查员兴趣的事情。她打给了科温，得知是洛夫特斯在背后搞鬼。洛夫特斯采访了尼科尔的寄养母亲、前继母、小时候认识她的家庭朋友。她甚至采访了尼科尔的生母，并说她可能被冤枉了。尼科尔听说洛夫特斯时，反应是：绝不可能。
Why did you want her to stop?
你为什么想让她停下？
I felt intruded upon. I felt violated, very vulnerable, very exposed. And I understand that that probably sounds weird, given that I had already given Dave my consent to publish a story about intimate details of my life. But there's a very, very big difference between someone asking you to investigate parts of your life and someone doing so without your knowledge or permission. I did exchange emails with her, and I asked her to stop what she was doing.
我感到受到侵犯。我感到被违背，非常脆弱，非常暴露。考虑到我已经同意戴夫发布关于我生活中私密细节的故事，我知道这听起来可能很奇怪。但有人要求你调查你生命中的部分，和有人在不知情或未经许可的情况下这样做，有非常、非常大的区别。我和她交换过邮件，我要求她停止她的行为。
And what did she say?
她说什么？
In so many words, no.
用那么多话来说，不。
Did she ask you any direct questions while she was looking into the case?
在她调查这个案子时，她问过你任何直接的问题吗？
No.
没有。
Did that strike you as kind of odd?
那让你觉得很奇怪吗？
It struck me as kind of infuriating.
那让我觉得非常愤怒。
Nicole complained to Loftus's university, who told her to stop investigating the Jane Doe case.
尼科尔向洛夫特斯的大学投诉，校方告诉她停止调查简·多伊案例。
I just got the call from some administrator on my campus, saying, are you looking into this case? I said, yes, I'm looking into this case. And they came and seized my files. I mean, I couldn't believe this was happening. When can the administrators come to your office and just take your files?
我接到校园管理员打来的电话，问我：“你在调查这个案子吗？”我说：“是的，我在调查这个案子。”他们就来没收了我的文件。我是说，我无法相信这在发生。管理员什么时候能来你的办公室拿走你的文件？
Loftus was eventually cleared, and she published her findings on Jane Doe. She argued that the abuse might never have happened. Of course, this was the opposite of what Nicole had believed and clung to since she was 17.
洛夫特斯最终被清除了嫌疑，她发布了关于简·多伊的发现。她争辩说虐待可能根本没发生。当然，这与尼科尔自17岁以来相信并坚持的东西相反。
Loftus printed eight pages worth of doubts in a magazine and called the article "Who Abused Jane Doe?" When Nicole heard the article was on stand, she took a friend from her military base and drove 50 miles to Barnes & Noble where they stood side by side reading it.
洛夫特斯在杂志上印了八页的怀疑，并把文章标题定为《谁虐待了简·多伊？》。尼科尔听到杂志上有这篇文章时，带上基地的一个朋友开了50英里到巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble），她们站在那儿读着。
It was so hurtful. It was so ridiculous to me that someone basically interviewed everyone in my life who had known me when I was a child, except me, and then went ahead and patchworked together this story that just so happened to completely support her hypothesis. How dare she? She just had no right. She just had no right to do what she did.
那太伤人了。对我来说太荒谬了，有人几乎采访了我生命中所有小时候认识我的人，除了我本人，然后拼凑出这个碰巧完全支持她假设的故事。她怎么敢？她根本没权利。她根本没权利做她做的事。
Whose story is this? This isn't just her story, this is the falsely accused mother's story. Other people are part of this story.
这是谁的故事？这不仅仅是她的故事，这是被冤枉母亲的故事。其他人也是这个故事的一部分。
I don't think one person gets to just decide, I'm going to only tell the story one way and only let people tell it who believe me uncritically. What about the other people in the story? I thought I was investigating an accusation against a possibly innocent person.
我不认为一个人能决定，“我只打算以一种方式讲述故事，只让那些无条件相信我的人讲述。”故事里的其他人呢？我以为我在调查针对一个可能无辜之人的指控。
I don't think the claim is that you should have just believed her uncritically. I think Nicole says that the way that you went around this research was sort of traumatizing and demoralizing to her. It made her feel like she didn't have any control over her own records and her own confidential information from her childhood. Can you put yourself in her shoes at all? Can you understand why she feels like this was a trespass?
我不认为那是说你应该无条件相信她。我觉得尼科尔说的是你进行这项研究的方式让她感到某种程度的创伤和挫折。这让她觉得她无法控制自己的记录以及童年的机密信息。你能稍微设身处地为她想一下吗？你能理解为什么她觉得这是一种冒犯吗？
Well, yes. I mean, I think she had her way of telling her story, and she didn't want there to be another way. And then that might be upsetting for her.
嗯，是的。我是说，我觉得她有她讲述故事的方式，她不想有另一种方式。那对她来说可能令人不安。
It doesn't seem to me like what she was upset by was that there was another way of telling the story. I think what she found upsetting was that you found out who she was and looked into her life without asking her or without thinking about her.
在我看来，她感到不安的并不是有另一种讲述方式。我觉得她发现令人不安的是你找出了她是谁，并在没问她或没考虑到她的情况下调查了她的生活。
Well, don't you think that that's what journalists do all the time?
嗯，你不觉得记者一直在做这种事吗？
Usually, when you write a story about someone, you contact them, or you ask them what they think of the things that you found out.
通常情况下，当你写关于某人的故事时，你会联系他们，或者问问他们对你发现的东西有什么看法。
Actually, I-- you know, there were times when I would have liked to have talked to her. I think I even wrote up some questions that I might want to ask her. But in the end, we decided that it was just too risky.
事实上，我是……你知道，有些时候我想过和她谈谈。我想我甚至写下了一些我想问她的问题。但最后，我们决定那风险太大了。
Risky, how?
风险怎么大？
I just remember there were going to be conditions. And it just made us nervous. And so we decided we would just publish what we had found out through many, many other sources and leave it at that. And that's what we did.
我只记得会有各种条件。这让我们紧张。所以我们决定通过许多、许多其他来源发布我们发现的东西，就这样了。这就是我们所做的。
Nicole sued with the help of a lawyer who took her case for free. They went after Loftus and everyone who'd helped write the article for 21 complaints, from defamation to invasion of privacy. But even though she was angry with Loftus, Nicole read her article over and over again, until something happened that she wasn't expecting. She found herself agreeing with Loftus a little.
尼科尔在免费代理的律师帮助下起诉了。他们就21项投诉，从诽谤到侵犯隐私，针对洛夫特斯和所有帮助写文章的人。但尽管她对洛夫特斯感到愤怒，尼科尔还是一遍又一遍地阅读她的文章，直到发生了一些她没想到的事。她发现自己有点同意洛夫特斯的观点了。
It planted a seed of doubt. It did, yes.
它种下了一颗怀疑的种子。确实是的。
What was that like to feel like there's this thing that you've been so certain of for so long, that you felt like you had resolution of with Dr. Corwin and seeing those tapes, and then to have it be the subject of doubt again? What did that do to you?
当你再次对那件事感到怀疑，而那件事你曾那么确定，你曾觉得和科温医生以及看了录像带后得到了解决，那种感觉如何？那对你做了什么？
It made me feel very small. It made me feel very insignificant, as though my opinion on my own-- the events of my own life were the least important.
这让我感到非常渺小。这让我觉得非常微不足道，好像我对……对自己生命中事件的看法是最不重要的。
Nicole started changing her mind back and forth, over and over. Some days, she thought she'd been abused, other days, she thought she'd lied about it.
尼科尔开始来回改变主意，一遍又一遍。有些日子，她认为自己被虐待了，有些日子，她认为自己撒谎了。
I have to say, as someone who spent months looking into Loftus's article, it is really hard to work out the responsible thing to think. When I first read it, I remember thinking, game over. There's no way Nicole's mom abused her. But as I looked into each claim Loftus made, what had seemed like a nine on the convincingness scale turned out to be more like a four. Like Loftus found a report from another psychologist who'd interviewed young Nicole, who said she sounded mechanical and rehearsed when she talked about abuse.
我必须说，作为一个花了几个月研究洛夫特斯文章的人，弄清楚该如何负责任地思考真是太难了。我第一次读到它时，我记得我想，“完蛋了”。尼科尔的母亲绝不可能虐待她。但当我研究洛夫特斯提出的每一项主张时，看似9分的说服力变成了4分。比如洛夫特斯发现另一位心理学家采访年轻尼科尔的报告，那人说她在谈论虐待时听起来机械且排练过。
Loftus told me that was the evidence that impressed her most, but I don't know. He says, quote, "Nicole has told her story numerous times to a number of different people, and she now sounds mechanical." He could mean Nicole's lying, or he could just mean she's been asked to tell it too many times.
洛夫特斯告诉我那是最让她印象深刻的证据，但我不知道。他说，引用：“尼科尔曾无数次向许多不同的人讲述她的故事，现在听起来像机械人一样。”他可能意思是尼科尔在撒谎，也可能仅仅是她被要求讲述太多次了。
And Loftus interviewed Nicole's step-mom, a woman who'd been there for the custody battle. She told Loftus that she and Nicole's dad had tried to win custody with what she called the sexual angle. Loftus heard that as sinister. But did she accidentally reveal that she'd had an agenda? Or did she just use sexual angle as an unfortunate shorthand, like saying, we won custody with the abuse thing?
洛夫特斯采访了尼科尔的继母，那个在监护权之争中在场的人。她告诉洛夫特斯，她和尼科尔的父亲试图用她所说的“性角度”赢得监护权。洛夫特斯觉得这很邪恶。但她是不小心透露了她有某种议程吗？还是她仅仅把“性角度”当作不幸的简写，就像说“我们用虐待那事赢得了监护权”？
And take the burns. Loftus found out that Nicole has a fungal condition that makes skin peel like a healing burn. But there are photos of young Nicole's feet with big blisters. Could they be explained by a fungus? It genuinely torments me. I still don't know what to think.
还有那些烫伤。洛夫特斯发现尼科尔有一种真菌疾病，导致皮肤像愈合的烫伤一样剥落。但有年轻尼科尔脚上有大水泡的照片。它们能被真菌解释吗？这真的折磨着我。我至今不知道该想什么。
Every piece of evidence seems to pinball back and forth like this. I went mad trying to find out the answer. I thought if I read enough court documents, I'd finally find the one thing that no one else had, the thing that would give me certainty either way. Of course, I didn't.
每一件证据似乎都像这样弹来弹去。我为了找到答案简直要疯了。我以为如果我读了足够的法庭文件，最终会找到其他人没有的那一件，那件能给我确定性结论的东西。当然，我没有找到。
And Nicole didn't either. She sat every day in the suspended animation of not knowing, caught between two really distressing ways of seeing her past. In one, her mother abused her. In the other, her father manipulated her into lying. And because she lied, her innocent mother was cut out of her life and wrongly accused of abusing her child.
尼科尔也没找到。她每天都坐在那种不知道真相的悬浮动画里，困在两种看待过去的极其痛苦的方式之间。一种是，她母亲虐待了她。另一种是，她父亲操纵她撒了谎。因为她撒了谎，她无辜的母亲被逐出了她的生命，并被错误地指控虐待自己的孩子。
It just created this back and forth that I continue to live with today-- it did happen, it didn't happen. Some days, I fall somewhere in between.
这创造了这种我今天依然生活的来回——它发生了，它没发生。有些日子，我两者都不确定。
How disorienting was it to feel like you had the truth, and then you lost it?
当你觉得你拥有真理，然后失去了它，那种迷失感有多强？
Disorienting is a good word, but I don't think it fully captures. It goes to my identity. It really goes to the heart of who I am, and who I thought I was, and who I think I am. The most important, the key memory on which I rebuilt and then rebuilt again my identity has now been called into question. It's just frustrating multiplied by a million. It's just so, so frustrating.
迷失是一个好词，但我不认为它能完全捕捉。它涉及我的认同。它真的触及了我内心深处，我以为我是谁，以及我认为我是谁。重建并再次重建我认同的那个关键记忆现在受到了质疑。这仅仅是挫折乘以一百万。这真是……太、太让人挫败了。
There is an intangible to be gained from the process of transition from being a victim to becoming a survivor. And in my case, now all of a sudden, am I neither? I don't know. Am I either? I don't know.
从受害者转变为幸存者的过程是有形的价值。在我的案例中，突然之间，我是两者都不是吗？我不知道。我是两者之一吗？我不知道。
Nicole's lawsuit against Elizabeth Loftus dragged on and on over five years, all the way out to the California Supreme Court. In the end, Nicole lost. The First Amendment protected Loftus as a journalist. And Nicole had to pay legal fees, nearly a quarter of a million dollars, which she could not afford.
尼科尔对伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯的诉讼拖了五年，一直打到加州最高法院。最终，尼科尔输了。宪法第一修正案保护了作为记者的洛夫特斯。尼科尔不得不支付法律费用，近25万美元，她支付不起。
The court garnished her military wages. She quit the Navy, lost two houses, and her car was repossessed over all this. She filed for bankruptcy.
法院扣押了她的军队薪水。她退出了海军，失去了两所房子，她的车被收回了。她申请了破产。
These days, instead of being stuck between believing she was abused and believing that she wasn't, Nicole's found a third option. She tries to care a little less. She can't dial down the uncertainty, so she tries to dial down the stakes.
这些日子，不再卡在相信自己被虐待和相信自己没被虐待之间，尼科尔找到了第三个选择。她试着少在乎一点。她无法调低不确定性，所以她试着调低赌注。
I'm never going to know. I'm never going to know. And even after all these years, I think I still thought that at some point I would come to a solid decision, yes or no. And really, really, I'm never going to know. And that just has to be OK.
我永远不会知道。我永远不会知道。即使过了这么多年，我想我还是觉得在某个点上我会做出坚定的决定，是的或不是。而真的，真的，我永远不会知道。那仅仅得是可以接受的。
There's so much that Nicole can't be certain of, so she hammered out a certainty about herself. She found a way forward. She became a pilot. She got two master's degrees and a PhD in psychology. She's now a therapist, like she's wanted since she was six.
尼科尔无法确定的事太多了，所以她锤炼出了关于自己的确定性。她找到了前进的道路。她成了一名飞行员。她获得了两个硕士学位和心理学博士学位。她现在是一名治疗师，正如她六岁时想要的那样。
And she's never cut her mom out of her life. Nicole's mom has always said that she never abused Nicole. She maintains that today. And she says she didn't tell Nicole to lie to Child Protective Services.
她从来没有把母亲逐出生命。尼科尔的母亲一直说她从未虐待过尼科尔。她今天仍坚持这一点。她说她没有告诉尼科尔对儿童保护服务撒谎。
Her mom's in her 70s. They live in the same state. It's not an easy relationship.
她母亲70多岁了。她们生活在同一个州。这不是一段容易的关系。
There's a possibility that I ruined my biological mother's life. There's a tremendous amount of guilt associated with that. We're close for-- well, we're relatively close for a period of time, and then things sort of fall apart again, just as they have.
有种可能性是我毁了我生母的生活。这关联着巨大的负罪感。我们……好吧，我们在一段时间里相对亲近，然后事情又分崩离析了，就像过去那样。
When was the last time that you spoke?
你们最后一次谈话是什么时候？
Five months ago.
五个月前。
And what was that like?
那是什么感觉？
It's still awkward. It's still very pressured, if you will. She still wants very much for me to believe that she never did anything to me, and I still don't know. So it's really, really hard to move past that major sort of elephant in the room.
依然尴尬。如果你愿意这么说的话，依然充满压力。她依然非常希望我相信她从来没对我做过什么，而我依然不知道。所以要跨过那个房间里的大象真的、真的很困难。
Do you ever talk about it?
你们谈过这件事吗？
No.
没有。
Is she able to accept that you might just not know?
她能接受你可能仅仅是不知道吗？
No, I think she really wants me to believe that she didn't.
不，我想她真的很希望我相信她没做过。
Do you think you could? Do you think there's anything that could change your mind?
你觉得你能吗？你觉得有什么事能改变你的主意吗？
No. The waters are so muddy now. There's no-- I'll never know one way or the other.
不。水现在太浑了。没有……我永远不会知道真相。
Nicole is no more certain about what happened today than she was when she was 16. She never flipped a coin and picked something to believe, but she landed on a certainty about what to do, that doesn't rest on what to believe. It doesn't matter what the evidence says, she wants her mom.
尼科尔今天对发生的事并不比她16岁时更确定。她从没掷硬币挑选去相信什么，但她对该怎么做得到了确定性，这不依赖于去相信什么。无论证据怎么说，她想要她的母亲。
Eleanor Gordon-Smith. A version of this story is in her new book, Stop Being Reasonable: How We Really Change Our Minds.
埃莉诺·戈登-史密斯。这个故事的一个版本在她新书《停止理智：我们如何真正改变主意》（Stop Being Reasonable: How We Really Change Our Minds）里。
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming and Emanuele Berry. The people who put our show together includes Whitney Dangerfield, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hillary Elkins, Damien Graef, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德鲁明（Neil Drumming）和埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）制作。我们节目的制作团队包括惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、希拉里·埃尔金斯（Hillary Elkins）、达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·纳尔逊（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
Special thanks today to John and Joe Teche, a.k.a. The Jetsyns, Amy Burtain, Michelle Johnson, and Keith Woods. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
特别感谢约翰和乔·特切（John and Joe Teche），即“Jetsyns”、艾米·伯坦（Amy Burtain）、米歇尔·约翰逊（Michelle Johnson）和基思·伍兹（Keith Woods）。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交流中心）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our show's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He is so excited about the superhero he created, this guy who gets bit by a radioactive seagull, patrols the beaches, saving lives. Torey swears it's super popular.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他对自己创造的那个超级英雄感到如此兴奋，那个被放射性海鸥咬了一口、巡逻海滩拯救生命的家伙。托雷发誓那超级受欢迎。
The Gulman is getting huge. The Gulman is getting huge.
古尔曼越来越壮了。古尔曼越来越壮了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - BRENDA RUSSELL, "A LITTLE BIT OF LOVE"]
（音乐 - 布兰达·罗素《一点点爱》）
(SINGING) A little bit of love can go a long, long way. So what you're thinking of.
（演唱）一点点爱就能走过漫长的路。所以你想的是。